hello and welcome to footnotes as per
the usual I'm here to recap the most
ravishing ideas from around wired today
we have a special aquatic episode in
honor of a deep-sea celebrity caught
flashing the paparazzi with what appear
to be it's naughty bits it's the giant
squid and it was captured on camera in
its natural environment as discussed by
Laura Schulberg and his alt text column
the giant squid is terrifying for a
number of reasons even though it has big
adorable anime eyes consider that it can
grow to over 40 feet long and that it
has a beak and that its suction cups
have serrated edges essentially making
it a big swimming eagle with slicey arms
the giant squid was the inspiration for
the Kraken of Norse folklore one of
history's great haters and it was this
kind of creature that made an appearance
in Jules Verne's 20,000 Leagues Under
the Sea shown here in great detail
because the artist had a lot of time to
burn after spending literally four
seconds on the birds overhead but the
giant squid isn't even the biggest squid
in the sea that honor goes to the
colossal squid this species has hooks on
its tentacles instead of serrated edges
so that noise a museum in new zealand
has one of these colossal squids on
display and on their website you can
even build your own specimen my colossal
squid is named Donnie and he has anger
problems so giant and colossal squid
exhibit what is known as deep-sea
gigantism or he gaunt ism if you're
Spanish this is most common with
invertebrates who grow big and tough
because they have no spines and are sick
of being called spineless but there is a
truly freakish deep sea vertebrate it's
the oarfish and it can reach a length of
almost 60 feet here you can see it get a
mistaken for a battering ram the oarfish
can be found all over the world and was
likely the source of sea serpent legends
it's not hard to imagine it surfacing
and greeting you by spitting which is
like humans spitting into their palms
and shaking hands except the sea serpent
has no hands but it's trying to fit in
scientists aren't yet sure why exactly
such deep sea creatures get so big
though it may be an adaptation to
extreme pressures another terrifying
example is the Japanese spider crab
whose leg span can be as long as three
and a half meters or 12 feet if you're
into puns these creatures can live as
long as 100 years and are said to be
docile like kitties and puppies and a
rabid mountain lions and there's really
no telling what other giant beasts might
be lurking down there but you can bet
that if anyone finds something it'll be
James Cameron and his awesome sub and
he'll probably name whatever he
discovers after the fabled monster
Celine Dion who sank the Titanic with a
smash hit my heart will go on
you